a clothing drive is aiming to help keep  our homeless veterans warm this winter  with veterans day right around the  corner this drive was organized by a  group named warriors for life america  people were dropping off jackets hats  and gloves at the arts district downtown  the founder of wfla says many veterans  feel isolated when they return to  civilian life  they feel alone they feel  hopeless and uncertain and  like nobody is there to help them so we  want to make sure we completely change  that message for them and show them that  we are here for them the community is  here for them  catholic charities and other  organizations will help make sure the  clothes get to those vets who need them  the drive ends at six so you still have  a little while to drop off those  donations